- How many times
where brand managers,
who have so many other duties
on top of being the
one who judges subjectively
if this video is nice,
how many times did he or
she say not that one, that one
and it was
actually the other one that
would have
changed their business?
I think that we are crippled by
a fantasy in Corporate America
marketing that doesn't exist.
It's no different than voice.
This needs to be
on voice, on brand.
Cool, who's the judge and the
jury of it being on brand?
Because I know everybody
in here either has done this
or has been on the
other side of this which is
the brand is snarky,
Rick thinks your
creative is snarky.
He goes on his
normal 18 month rotation.
Sally walks in and
goes, "What is this crap?
"This isn't snarky."
You know, and most of all,
we have audacity.
Do you know what audacity is?
We have insane audacity in our
ivory towers of marketing
thinking we know
what people want.
First of all, there's 87 to
4,000 different psychographic
clusters of the
people that are seeing this.
Which is the point which is,
to answer your question,
2017 make six commercials.
Make them two minutes long,
actually make them
creative not commercials.
Make them a documentary type
thing or a sit-com type thing
or a music video thing.
Actually star the people that
you're trying to reach in it.
So, you know, I always say this
to my friends I'm like,
"Why do you think BET
"over-indexes with African
Americans? They're in it."
Like if you want a
Latina woman to buy your product
why don't you put one in the
video and then this is crazy
stick with me, this is nuts,
and then you market
to Latino women
and they actually see it.
It's crazy you can do this now.
It's called Facebook. Right?
And, I don't even, you know,
honestly, I feel like jumping
out the window right now.
(hip hop music)